these are homemade wonton chips with two
types of fish let me show you how to
make it
so I'm using raw salmon and it's really
fatty tuna that I got from the cream
Market the salmon I'm cutting is a small
cubes and then for the tuna I'm mincing
it really fine most of the flavor for
the salmon is coming from the chili oil
and soy sauce try to add a little at a
time taste it and then adjust as you go
and then for the tuna I wanted to make
this one creamy so I'm adding QP mayo
and Sriracha as my base along with
sesame oil and sugar
then for the chips I'm using these
wonton wrappers that you just cut in
half and then deep fry until slightly
golden and crispy